[Music]
an apple made me do it is submitted by
in Russia to vodka drink you okay an
iPhone user is suing Apple for turning
him gay Oh what why would a polite that
that's [ __ ] up on their part as a
company what was the new update that's
why don't update does it makes you gay
slowly over time none of the new
features on your [ __ ] [ __ ] mode it
sucks man yeah yeah so this Russian man
is seeking more than fifteen thousand
dollars in damages from Apple after
claiming that they force him to be gay
only 15 jeez he's like it's not that bad
right you know I kind of like I suck
today I was pretty good he's like they
called a lot and like I'd run up a real
drink tab so what happened was during
one summer you received 69 gay coins on
a cryptocurrency payment app that he had
downloaded a coins on 69 nine and so the
unwritten sender included an
english-language message that said don't
judge without trying so that's when this
man says I thought indeed how can I
judge something without trying it and
decided to try same-sex relations you
saw all the minded you got a point there
till you try it
I got it sent a bunch of [ __ ] token and
yeah it made me want to [ __ ] for sure
well if it was 69 you'd probably
consider it I would definitely consider
it but my wife's not into this bag right
so then he says I can say after the
passage of two months that I am married
and intimacy mired mired thank you I'm
mired in intimacy with a member of my
own sex and can't get out I have have a
steady boyfriend and I don't know how to
explain it to my parents and I can't
resist the D it's like [ __ ] you big gay
shut up steady boyfriend yeah a steady
boyfriend saying that he can't explain
to his parents and saying that his life
has changed for the worse and will never
be will never be normal again
stop Natalie what
[ __ ] boyfriend swinging pinkies all
day then it sounds like it's a shitty
boy he's going like this having a good
old time and this was blaming Apple yeah
I know just embrace it you're gay maybe
his boyfriend sucks no yeah maybe the
the honeymoon phase is over and that's
why he's getting angry at Apple cuz he's
like oh you should try a new boyfriend
yeah so this is what he's saying saying
[ __ ] rail manipulatively pushing me
towards homosexuality which causes him
moral suffering and harm to mental
health
so he's suing them for 1 million ruble
ruble which is fifteen thousand three
hundred you don't understand you make me
gay up and how though you got an exodus
wall order some [ __ ] and because you got
tokens probably through airdrop that
made him gay I don't understand I side
with him why is it almost fall and not
the fault that ball has more money oh
you know you always seems like the
bigger company or if they never had the
app I want to talk to the lawyer I took
this case he was like you know what me
too this happened to me I hate my gay
life now we have to fight against this
now I see dick everywhere my briefcase
full of dildos this all of them in my
life oh wow really
that's a Gilbert roof here I really look
at a has more utility than just having
business papers in there where you go
still does for sure yeah I cannot please
this dick every day
so what is it is it in court so they're
saying that's he had registered this
lawsuit and they are scheduled and they
scheduled an interview for later on this
month I didn't know that Apple can make
you gay maybe I should change to Android
hey dude I'm kind of scared the CEO of
Apple is good right oh that's nip you
leading everyone to be gay ever since
that I didn't update my phone see
I was like my turn and gave what if you
start to develop this acquired taste
later in life and then you want to leave
your wife and start sucking some dick
that's why I'm saying if I know one
thing about gay people is that they
always got an agenda yeah like Ruby
rather the gay agenda you should the gay
agenda is interior designing your makeup
or clothed like makeovers they're always
they're always trying to make people
over giving straight guys really nice
makers coy finger hair nicely yup yeah
boy you better watch out you might be
going national how do you know so much
about coy finger hmm I already got two
I've already been gotten to enough by
the gay agenda I don't need it to go are
you gonna join his lawsuit make it a
class action law I might do my own well
you haven't been updating so you're not
affected by it that's true good yeah I
think I'm okay right now
once we see Steve with a strong fashion
sense I'd be I'd be like I think he's
turning gay if I see you with an ascot
game over once I stop wearing shorts
with loafers look out okay then I
upgraded my fashion yes I thought he had
a dick in his mouth but then once he's
smashing change wait what why stop at
15,000 now I feel like if you're gonna
go it's something ridiculous like number
sounds crazy
it's a million in his gun oh yeah it's a
million is country so might be huge over
there yeah there might be a like what do
you call it like a litigation cap like I
don't know cuz in other countries they
don't you can't do the whole Kuwait what
if he wins and to troll them they just
give him 15,000 gay coins on me and
Nikki's podcast we were doing a bit
where I was did a bit during the ad
break where I we had this very nice
lesbian on and I pretended to be do
those mean ones though right she was
actually one of the nicer ones I was
doing a fake ad for a conversion therapy
place that actually works it's not one
of those [ __ ] conversion therapies
that doesn't work Larry yeah or your get
your money back or whatever yeah this
chicks just the cost would be like [ __ ]
it like oh my god is this really buy on
the show oh no like she saw like her
entire oh just like I always judge baby
the [ __ ] head make it and make it up at
the straight face it's like yeah you
know how you when you go to converted
therapy and then
right and you leave there and you're
still thinking about it you [ __ ] or
whatever yeah they look like that kind
of thing but I cleaned it up so this one
doesn't believe in electrocution this
one doesn't believe in waterboarding
they'd do it the nice way exactly from a
code Steve it's actually effect run
block code exactly get 20% off all that
[ __ ] I did the whole the Bears are more
of a Nikki just always sits a roll her
eyes and can't [ __ ] believe you do it
yeah but then she actually believed you
know Nikki didn't know no oh yeah the
chick was kind of like oh my god what
has happened wait is that real was that
real did you ever tell her it was it
course not good move on you the first
time I did your podcast I think you the
bit brand deal you did it was like four
hangers or something you know these are
so good that not only did they stick to
the wall but they'll stick to the
ceiling wall and ceiling like
transitions sounds real steel no it's
pretty cool but then as Steve starts
going in on those my first anime radio
series
that's always fun for me like I got the
guy who does the game show there's a
game show on your phone where they give
you like Matt from HQ trivia yeah Bucky
very nice guy black dude we just called
my black friend from HQ trim I did so
yeah he was on a podcast and I did an ad
break for a trivia place that doesn't
actually after the show he's like come
on man is that's the [ __ ] what's
going on are we sick of this [ __ ]
trivia show that sucks complete asses I
got these [ __ ] hosts that do [ __ ]
jokes like we got a [ __ ] great I
stopped doing about a couple weeks but
I'm gonna get back on it it's fun I had
to take a break but stick it at ol a
break cuz it if you expect it to be fake
every time you mean you gotta [ __ ]
thread it in a little yeah I think if
you do it with like new guests I don't
know you that well the best I think the
bit will be yeah the new guest
yeah and how they react to it anyway
yeah here this guy suing Apple for
turning them away so is it legit like
they're taking this to court and all
this stuff but yeah that's
like I want to know who which lawyer is
this in Russia or was that Russia okay
in Moscow oh yeah I would love to see
his case like him but the PowerPoint
being like look here's a graph of zero
dicks and then pictures of him just like
sucking [ __ ] Exhibit A when I was three
you see me with woman yes now here I am
with with men I'm gay my life is
relationships that's the best part
steady relationship not just I'm with
men
no it's steady like I love this guy so
much like yeah I am ruined how do I tell
my parents it just kind of sounds like
he got into relationship with the guy he
doesn't know how to break up with and so
he has to sue at work oh that's a good
point right what sucks about my branding
is if I tried to come out to my parents
they'd be like yeah right for [ __ ] 10
Steve I know see Barry potty Steve if
you smell like [ __ ] stick to your
Gilbert if you try to come out to your
parents my parents are freaked out
they're Catholic hardcore Phil okay oh
there's somebody gave Filipino that's
the weird thing about like the
Philippines - they're number one in like
mr. gay thank or gay sir there's a mr.
gay and Philippines like a ranked number
one Filipinos are pretty gay like mr.
gay magazine what is it mr. well might
be mr. universe or mister like you see
in this magazine well no like it sounds
like a thing like mr. gay magazine like
a pageant the pageant yeah like Miss
America yeah so actually like even Bob
Mihkel all over in the Philippines
actually I can't say they're gay they're
just minute like to crossdress
they're like 12 what they call it mr.
gay but they caught mr. gay I don't
think they're with women ever but
they're not gay
they just like to perform I see I think
Bob is actually judge on one of these
it's called mr. gay I'm saying like I
think just in general this is say out
because that's a dope pageant name
he's paraphrasing one addiction oh it's
mr. homosexual but like there you go
basically these pageants they have the
Philippines you small towns they have to
do like tricks like acrobatic so it's
like they wear a bathing suit or they
dress up they do a dance they sing but
they always do crazy [ __ ] to outdo the
other person kind like jackass like
apparently Bob McClure telling me when
they were judging one guy came out and
then sort of it was on a high school gym
start crawling up the bleachers like a
spider and then jumping did a backflip
and landing on his back
flamethrower it just started like oh
thank you so much that's good because
he's blame it so take a weird thing
where they just perform oh yeah I'm
getting there new and it brings up the
flame you know who would top that it
always goes to fire with the gays yeah
oh is that fire-breathing fire dancing
putting hot cheetos on a Dickens AG
again oh I've heard oh that's a fire
festival right there
[Music]